se ríen y se divierten en la fiesta de
purím es difícil imaginar que estos
niños hayan huido de un país en guerra a
principios de marzo fueron evacuados de
su orfanato judío en odessa ucrania y
apenas están empezando a recuperar una
apariencia de normalidad gracias en
parte al rabino que los acompañó a
alemania
veo que te gusta comer y buena comida
la fiesta de purím celebra la
supervivencia del pueblo judío frente a
la persecución un riesgo alegre que este
año adquiere un nuevo significado para
men the wolf cuyo bisabuelo huyó de la
alemania nazi
si viviera hoy y viera que los judíos de
ucrania huyen de los rusos a berlín y
son acogidos allí por abrazos y tanta
ayuda él estaría no lo sé no lo puedo
explicar
un centenar de huérfanos de odessa
llegaron a berlín pero también madres
solteras y adolescentes que dejaron
atrás una parte de sus familias
sinceramente estoy feliz pero en el
fondo sigo pensando en esta guerra
pienso en eso todo el tiempo me refiero
me gusta estar aquí pero en casa es
mejor siempre es mejor estar en casa
obrar obligados a tomar el camino del
exilio miles de judíos ya han amontonado
ucrania para llegar a israel pero tomen
a alemania y a su comunidad judía o
rusoparlante asentada allí desde el
final de la era soviética el centro
religioso que acoge a los niños se
prepara para la llegada de un nuevo
convoy de 150 refugiados durante todas
estas personas están completamente
traumatizadas pero ahora podemos acoger
los en alemania y el hecho de que puedan
volver a este país 80 años después de
haber huido el hecho de que alemania sea
ahora un refugio para los judíos es una
señal muy fuerte pero todos ellos
esperan volver algún día o des a una
ciudad impregnada de cultura judía casi
la mitad de los 30.000 judíos de la
ciudad portuaria ya se han marchado a
otros países